albert einstein gilt es für unmöglich
doch jetzt wurde tatsächlich zum ersten
mal einen stern im weltraum gewogen
forscher und forscherinnen von der
university baltimore in den usa bedienen
sich dabei eines tricks den schon albert
einstein vorhergesagt hatte quasi die
einstein sternen waage allerdings
glaubte er nie daran dass sie auch
eingesetzt werden könnte wie das
funktioniert jetzt entwicklung science
fiction herzlich willkommen das wiegen
von sternen und planeten bisher immer
eine ziemlich komplizierte angelegenheit
unfähige daten mussten gesammelt werden
die himmelskörper klassifiziert umlauf
geschwindigkeiten berechnet werden die
zusammensetzung des ausgestrahlten
lichtes analysiert werden und so weiter
und so fort irgendwann hatte man so
ungefähr das gewicht dabei hat das
universum eine eingebaute waage und mal
wieder lässt albert einstein größen
die gravitation also die krümmung der
raumzeit durch große matten ermöglicht
es beim passieren von zwei
himmelskörpern das gewicht des vor dem
zweiten himmelskörper liegenden
gestürmt exakt zu bestimmen beobachten
wir also von der erde aus einem stern
und schickt sich ein zweiter stern davor
können wir das gewicht wer sich davor
schieben sterns bestimmen angewiesen
er kommt nämlich die raumzeit so dass
sich ein so genannter einsteinring um im
bilde der raum wird so gekrümmt dass
der stern hinter ihm jetzt als ring im
immer herum erscheinen je nach
ausprägung des ringens können gesehen
wie stark der vordere sternfahrt krümmt
und damit kennen wir seine gravitation
und damit wieder um sein gewicht in
einer abhandlung in der zeit zur zeit
beschäftigt mich ein stein mit dieser
möglichkeit erhielt allerdings die
wahrscheinlichkeit einen solchen ring zu
beobachten für nahezu unmöglich
mit der sonne war etwas ähnliches aber
990 jungen bei einer sonnenfinsternis
konnte beobachtet werden dass die sterne
die neben der sonne zu gehen war nicht
da waren wo wir eigentlich hätten sein
sollen wie waren um 16 198 bogensekunden
verschoben einstein war so damals
bewiesen worden eine sensation er hatte
mit seiner absurden theorie tatsächlich
recht der relativitätstheorie anhand
der position dieser sterne
während der songs
dann ist konnte die masse der sonne
gewogen werden das aber einen
einsteinring beobachtet werden können
da fehlt albert einstein aber eben für
unmöglich und auch der beteiligte
astronom keiner so beschreibt das
unterfangen als extrem schwierig zitat
es war wie die messung der bewegung
eines kleinen leuchtkäfer vor einer
glühbirne 1500 meilen entfernt aber
genau das gelang jetzt mit dem hubble
weltraumteleskop der sternstein 20 51 b
schob sich dabei vor einem anderen stern
und der vorhergesagte einsteinring
erschien stein 20 51 b konnte gebogen
werden
dafür untersuchten bau und sein team
5000 sternen
die als linse funktionieren würden und
entschieden sich dann für eben stein 2
0 51
dank der beobachtung haben die
forscherinnen und forscher jetzt eine
menge erfahren der stern mit 68 prozent
der sonne also rund 13 5 quadrillen
tonnen und er ist nur 100 meter breit
wie die sonne genau die werte die für
einen weißen zwerg wie ihn erwartet
wurden unter was für die forderung und
forscher eine überraschung denn
normalerweise passen messungen wählten
exakt zu vorhersagen da sie immer auch
mit neuen erkenntnissen verbunden sind
hier wurde die theorie aber eins zu eins
bestätigt jetzt ja wir sagen weitere
sterne wiegen einstein wäre
wahrscheinlich stolz wenn er trotz
seiner skepsis eine weitere bestätigung
seiner theorie erlebt hätte wenn die
relativitätstheorie weil mal wieder
bestätigt wird dann berichten wir
natürlich hier darüber wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann drücken wir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich
mir einen aufruf locker zu geben wenn
ihr die relativitätstheorie noch nicht
verstanden habt dann seht euch mein
video dazu an
das wird oft im unterricht gezeigt wenn
es wirklich glaube ich wirklich ziemlich
gut zu verstehen
die relativitätstheorie einfach
erklärt ansonsten bislang bleibt dran